[Music]
you
good evening I'm Stuart bran from the
long now foundation a couple of
announcements as usual when we're here
at the collar there's a reception
afterwards just down the street and
around the corner at the long now Museum
shop office and party pad
I'm told that outside after the show as
well as before you can save $5 on
tickets for the Maker Faire which is
coming up May 30th and 31st and the San
Mateo County Expo Center and one of the
reasons that we're in cahoots with them
on this is one it's a wonderful event
makers are people who as they say rip
the back off of technology and put their
hands in where they're not supposed to
and make things happen and I guess an
example of that long now is going to be
exposing for the first time one of the
mountain-sized parts of the 10,000 year
clock that we've been working on this
will be a how heavy is it Alexander
2,000 pounds of gear it's a the Geneva
wheel for the clock such as will go in
the mountain it's a working piece of
apparatus that will work as you watch if
you put your hand in it it will grind it
probably flat that will be the first
exposure of that piece of gear and
there's amazing things that the Maker
Faire I recommend it we had two talks in
May so we're gonna skip you and
everybody can take a vacation and at the
end of July the reply to part of Michael
Pollan will be pamela ronald and Rahl a
down track he is an organic farmer of
some major repute in California teaches
organic farming at the University of
California Davis his wife is pamela
ronald and she is a head of a genetics
engineering lab plant genetic
engineering lab at UC davis and they
make a very strong case that that
combination is the right thing to do
your food I'll be July 28th Paul Romer
is a economist who gets invoked a lot
and the reasons are is he's the the
primary founder and formulator of what's
called new growth theory and new growth
theory was a formal and persuasive way
to make sure that economic growth
realizes economic understanding realizes
the power of ideas so let's talk about
resources and these various economic
balances and so on but the ideas in
their own right are a powerful source of
the creation of wealth for a while now I
guess a couple of years he's been
working up on a new formulation which is
modestly calling a theory of history and
this is the launch of that there will be
a series of presentations that he'll be
making putting this idea forth and
putting it into application so please
welcome the first look at that set of
ideas from Paul Romer
I hope it was clear from the title that
there was a certain amount of
self-deprecation in the immodesty of
proposing a theory of history what I was
a physics student the typical exam
question that we used to talk about that
would be posed to us by our professors
was define universe and give two
examples and I think accepting the
assignment to propose a theory of
history and given application is almost
as difficult or as foolhardy as that but
I hope by the end of the evening all
have persuaded you that there is some
value to thinking about history from a
very abstract theoretical perspective
and value particularly from this point
of view of influencing what we do now
sometimes we we look at theories we can
create theories like cosmology in part
just because of their elegance really as
works of art as some of the highest
forms of human achievement but this this
talk tonight is not about a theory in
that sense it's really theory as a tool
I have a very specific application in
mind and we'll come to that at the end
so when you judge the theory keep in
mind that it's its application that
matters not the elegance per se but I'll
still try and give you something which
is tight simple has a few moving parts
that I hope you'll you'll remember now
what should a theory of history be able
to explain at a minimum it should be
able to describe data like this this is
a measure of the wage in terms of the
amount of light you could earn if you
took your efforts as a worker worked for
an hour then bought fuel with the
available technologies at a particular
point in time and then use that fuel to
produce light notice that it's a ratio
scale so over this roughly ten twelve
thousand year horizon we're seeing many
orders of magnitude increase in the
amount of light the lumens of light you
could get if you worked for in one hour
to get fuel to produce light so the most
striking fact that a theory of history
has to be able to account
for is this kind of improvement but it
also has to explain the time pattern
here with this kind of plot with a ratio
scale on the vertical axis and time on
the horizontal axis slopes are growth
rates so the rate of growth of this kind
of measure of wage has been accelerating
increasing over time so this is what
this is the sort of the minimum that any
theory of history has to account for why
is it possible for for things to be
getting so much better and why have
things been getting better faster as
time has proceeded now I've already said
something about the available
technologies of the time you can't think
about a chart like this without thinking
about technological change I've called
out here one data point which is the
point where Edison invented the electric
light bulb notice this was not the
beginning of this rapid upturn even
things like candles were very important
technologies that led to big
improvements compared to sesame oil in a
stone lamp but the electric light bulb
was clearly a very important part of
this this general process and and we
know that there's a series of
technologies that that lie behind behind
that that light bulb but we have to stop
and think about well what is it what
does it mean to say a technology what do
we mean by a technology here and this is
the this is the theory part the
abstraction how do we strip away the
essential and get to the to the heart of
this so what what are technologies well
for electric light there's a whole bunch
of things that had to work together
there's generation there's transmission
there's the light bulb let's let's just
strip this down to two one one very
simple part a simple technology is a
formula that says if you take iron and
mix a little bit of carbon in with it
you can make steel and then with steel
you can build things like the towers
that are part of this grand technology
that leads to light in in people's homes
so you can break these complicated
technologies down into very small parts
and the amount to formulas recipes
instructions but they're all about how
to use the physical objects in the world
differently how do we rearrange them in
a way that's more value
to us as humans another example that
pulls down even to a more simple kind of
application of this concept of a
technology one that many people have
found memorable is the idea of the the
cups that you can get in any coffee shop
these days it used to be that the cups
and the lids that the three different
sizes of cups that you could typically
find in a coffee shop all had their own
size lid and somebody made the insight
that if we redesigned the paper cups you
could use a single type of lid on all
three cups so it's a very simple idea
about rearranging the physical objects
in the universe around us the the wood
that then gets turned into paper that
didn't gets turned into cups but if we
did it in this slightly different way it
would save time and it was the
cumulative effect of any number larger
of innovations technologies formulas
like this that drives that drives human
progress and these improvements and
standards of living now
technologies have this remarkable
feature that makes them very different
from physical objects they interact with
people in exactly the opposite way that
physical objects interact as there were
more people on earth there was less land
available per person that's been a fact
all throughout human history
so with physical objects the more people
you have in some sense the worse off
each of us has to be but what I'm going
to argue analysis is that with
technologies the more people we have the
better off we can be because with
technologies these ideas these formulas
these recipes are things that we can
share and all use at the same time so
you and I may not be able to both form
the same square meter to raise our
organic food but you and I can both use
an insight about crop rotation or
fertilizers or a new type of new type of
seed so what this means is that if you
think about a historical dynamic where
you have more people there are more
people to go out and make discoveries
which leads to more of these
technologies but
because everybody can share the
technologies that means that you have
more technologies per person more
technologies more ideas per person
therefore leads to to more people and
then more people further Spurs the
discovery process which Spurs the makes
it possible for more and more people to
live on a given by a given piece of land
so that you can think about the broad
sweep of human history up until
relatively recent times as being a
positive feedback loop between people
and technologies that comes from this
special characteristic of shareability
of the of the technologies now it
wouldn't have to be the case that new
technologies alone would would dominate
the scarcity effects of less land it
could have been the case that as we had
more and more people having less land
per person led to less food per person
and no amount of discovery could
overturn that result so we might have
lived in a very harsh world like that
where there just wasn't enough to
discover that could offset the effects
of scarcity but judging from human
history that's not the kind of world we
lived in we have lived in we have much
more food per capita even with much less
land per capita than we had before and
it's because of all of the discoveries
that we've been able to make so the
simple story about this acceleration
over time in the standards of living
comes from positive feedback between
discovery and more people and then
combined in the most recent period with
a switch from patterns of fertility
where up until very recently new
technologies led to more food which led
to more people which did not lead to
more to higher standards of living but
in in the last several centuries humans
have gone through the demographic
transition which meant that at some
point the number of people what did not
keep up with the new technologies that
were just were being discovered income
per person started to go up that set off
another kind of explosive dynamic which
was as income per person starts to go up
for reasons that I think are still not
clear humans
end up deciding to limit fertility so
population growth couldn't keep up with
this accelerating process of
technological change standards of living
eventually start to rise that led to a
fall in fertility and that makes
standards of living grow even faster so
that gives you a kind of a simple
technological determinism theory of
history that can explain the broad
pattern of accelerating progress over
time but now what we need to do is bring
another critical element into this story
and I want to I want to tell that as
follows there there's a there's a
scholar who's looked at books about
manners during during the Middle Ages
and the kinds of things that these
manners books would teach people who
wanted to learn how to behave and
appropriately in modern society were
injunctions like this that if you're at
the table eating dinner and you need to
spit don't spit across the table over
the food of the people eating across
from you but turn over your shoulder and
spit behind you so you know these things
seem like things that we would you know
how could anybody not know that but if
you go back in time to two
hunter-gatherer societies you know you
didn't really have to worry very much
about where you could spit so as as we
went through this process of more
technology leading to more people
leading to more technology and
increasing density of people all of a
sudden we started to have interactions
with each other which called for rules
for managing potential negative
spillovers between between people I'll
give you another example we've had a
number of technological innovations and
phishing better ships better lines
better nets ways to catch fish much more
efficiently so a given number of people
or a given amount of capital investment
can catch many more fish without the
right kinds of rules those technological
advances can do an enormous amount of
harm to the world's to the world's
fisheries and in fact in many cases
unfortunately they have in a few cases
we've actually been able to supplement
those technological advances with
appropriate rules which limit the catch
to the sustainable yield and
you get the benefits of technology it
takes less human effort to catch the
sustainable yield of fish without any of
the harm so for both of these reasons
spillover is associated with density and
potential side effects negative side
effects associated with technology we
need to think about rules as well as
technologies so the the theory of
history that I want to propose here is
one that involves two different types of
ideas that when we contrast the the
properties of scarce physical objects
that can't be shared with ideas which
can be shared and can be reused we want
to think about technological ideas but
also rules so we've spoken about the
technologies technologies are just ways
to rearrange physical objects to make
them more valuable to us let's think
about what what rules are well rules are
just ways to structure the interactions
that people have with each other
so if technologies are just structuring
physical objects just structuring matter
in ways that are more valuable rules are
structuring our interactions to make
sure that we get the most value out of
those interactions they could be as
simple as drive on the right or drive on
the left doesn't really matter which one
you pick
but you better pick one as density of
road traffic starts to increase just
notice for reference that we'll come
back to in a minute that once you pick
one of these conventions it becomes hard
to change so if you end up in an area
where your rules are drive on the left
where everybody else around you is drive
on the right it might be efficient for
you to switch your your system but it
may be very hard to do so rules can be
as simple as driving on the left or on
the right another very important rule in
human history was the concept of
ownership think back again to
hunter-gatherer societies ownership was
not an important concept or convention
there but as as we developed we
established this new convention that we
would assign to certain people the
concept of ownership over a particular
piece of property which meant that no
one else could take advantage of that
property without the approval
the person who who had this this
ownership right and then associated with
this ownership right were conventions
about what do you do when those rules
are violated any rule like this amongst
humans will end up with violations early
in human history violations of rules
like challenges to one's honor
or theft of theft of property like like
animals and most societies led to
overwhelming retribution and vengeance
in in response over time we evolved a
notion of the right way to respond to a
violation of these conventions about
ownership with was with a notion of
damages rather than violent retribution
damages which were proportional to the
harm and which rather than destroying
value just shifted value from the person
who caused the harm to the person who
who suffered it so ownership carries
with it
lots of conventions lots of rules about
what does it mean when we stick to these
rules and then how do we respond when
people don't stick to them more recent
forms of rules are the rules that
support open science in science we
reward someone who makes a discovery not
by by giving them an ownership right but
by giving them recognition and the key
to getting recognition for a discovery
is to be the first one to publish it so
priority is the critical determinant of
who gets the recognition the prize the
rewards in the scientific community that
of course creates strong incentives for
people to get information out as soon as
they discover it that turns out to be a
very good rule for taking what's known
in science getting it widely shared so
others can then take what you've
discovered and build on it to make a
subsequent discovery so these rules can
interact with the technologies that we
described a minute ago the discovery of
the potential for cultivating wheat led
almost inevitably to the evolution of
rules about ownership of land that if
you're cultivating a piece of land you
need to have an incentive to do the work
that's required to make the wheats grow
you need to be able to capture the
returns from that you
let others come in under the conventions
of say hunter-gatherer societies and
just take whatever they want whenever
they want so this is a case where a
technological development almost surely
spurred the the new sets of the new sets
of rules there are other cases where it
goes the other direction the patent
system in the United States was a very
important collection of rules which were
different from the rules of open science
but which gave Thomas Edison the
potential for monetary gain if he could
come up with a better incandescent light
bulb and that was a critical force
spurring him to make the discovery that
led to the the first practical light
bulb but in parallel we had the
institutions of science which we're
developing Maxwell's equations and all
of the understanding of electricity and
magnetism which were required for
building out the transmission systems
for developing the dynamos so it took
both the institutions of property and
patents and the institutions of science
to get those kinds of discoveries that
led to the light that we saw in the the
very first the very first slide now the
discussion so far makes it sound as if
good rules will be forthcoming whenever
we need them and whenever we want them
but if you look around the world we see
that the story about the evolution of
these rules is actually much more
complicated a good indication of that is
to just take the map of the world at
night and look at the various sources of
light and then zoom in on one particular
area the Korean Peninsula and the Korean
Peninsula there is literally a black
hole where there is no light but we know
many people live there the same
technologies that generate light for
people everywhere else in the world
could be used in North Korea but
something clearly prevents those from
actually being put to use there so
there's something very extreme about the
rules in North Korea which mean that
existing technologies don't get used
there and certainly important new
technologies don't get discovered there
so there's a potential
rules to turn harmful to slow us down
and sadly for those to persist for very
long periods of time again think back to
the story about driving on the left
versus driving on the right from the
broad historical perspective China is
the case that most calls out for this
amendment to the simple story of a
feedback between people and technologies
because China was in the Middle Ages as
that story would predict well ahead of
the rest of the world there's a whole
list of important technologies that were
developed first in China like steel like
gunpowder decimals the wheelbarrow the
list goes on and on but around around a
thousand 1200 with the Ming Dynasty a
new set of rules were imposed in China
that brought progress there to a halt
technological progress there and which
kept them for centuries from even being
able to take advantage of technologies
that were developed in other parts of
the world to show this in a graph the
the scale here now is a linear scale of
income per capita in 1990 dollars so if
we converted to today's dollars the
numbers would look a little bit bigger
these are estimates of and these are
very crude estimates but estimates of
income per capita going back to the Year
1000 in China and whoever was the world
leader at various points in time and and
if you looked if we zoomed way in on
that point 1,000 historical estimates
are that at that point China was ahead
but China then entered into almost a
thousand years of stagnation as the
leading countries in the world went
zooming zooming far ahead so there's a
potential for new rules like the patent
system like open science to speed up the
rate of technological change and speed
up discover speed up improvements in
standards of living so that acceleration
we saw in the in the leading countries
is not just a function of more people
leading to more discoveries but in
recent periods it's been more people
discovering because there
rules that give them better incentives
to discover and better ways to work with
each other as they all engage in the
discovery process so rules can amplify
this accelerating process that was first
driven just by pop population growth but
rules can also stifle and slow progress
down and can do so for many centuries so
the history theory of history that we
have to work out here is one where we
allow for this dynamic of Technology but
we think about what's the underlying
dynamic of the rules wider rules
sometimes get better in a way that makes
everyone better off wider rules
sometimes trap us in a way that seems so
so harmful to all and so wasteful now to
think about what the dynamic is I want
to invoke an analogy at this point I
want you to think not about countries
but think about companies for a minute
and zoom in to much narrower piece of
history think about the recent IT
revolution and in the United States go
back to innovations that started at IBM
with the 360 line of mainframes and the
emergence of centralized computing in
important important commercial
applications then think about the
emergence of a company like Wang which
pioneered the was one of the company's
pioneering the development of computing
that was closer to the user and
applications like word processing which
became available to users when the
computing power was closer Whang emerged
competed with IBM developed an important
niche but was was soon eclipsed
Apple came in with was one of the first
companies others had tried but one of
the first companies to move computing
all the way to the end-user
IBM then responded with its own personal
computer personal computers took off
word processing became available on
personal computers wang completely lost
the word processing business but
throughout this process the applications
and the functionality we could achieve
all got all got better critical elements
in this dynamic were things like
new entry at one point there was no Wang
computing at one point there was no
Apple but those companies could enter do
things differently when they enter there
was a process of copying
so Apple pushes the the PC IBM copies
with its own version of the PC there are
also cases like like it Wang where
there's really no future for that
organization and workers and customers
get reallocated to other companies
selling other products developing other
products and Wang shrinks but progress
for the system as a whole moves ahead
so imagine imagine what what would
happen what would happen if we couldn't
have any new companies your first
reaction might be well Moore's law
should still operate technology should
should still keep improving but if you
look at the history these social
organizations these people working
together under particular rule sets were
critical drivers of technological change
and the kind of rule set that was
operating at IBM was very powerfully
powerful powerfully productive for some
period of time but it it became less
effective in a later in a later period
new organizations emerged where a whole
collection of people operated according
to a different set of rules were able to
compete with IBM take some of its
business away IBM changed some of its
rules and in response to this
competition but other organizations like
Wang did not if we couldn't have that
process of competition that drives IBM
to change that brings in the ideas from
Wang or brings in the ideas at Apple
it's it's very likely that we would have
had much slower progress in the IT
industry and this is a kind of a warning
to us to ourselves that the rules really
do matter here that we can't just think
of the technologies as operating
according to their own their own
inherent time clock and we can you can
arrange things so that there are new
countries and new companies that emerge
or not and it's very important in our
economy that we can
fact have new new companies now let me
tell this story again about countries
instead of companies so think about
think about the process of world
leadership in productivity the
Netherlands in the 16th and early 17th
century was the world leader in
commercial establishments that developed
stock markets they pioneered the
financial crisis with the with the tulip
bubble it was a it was a it was a
country which attracted many migrants
from throughout throughout Europe grew
very rapidly because of that that
migration and for a period was was the
world leader but then over time
leadership moved to the United Kingdom
we saw the early applications of
engineering applied science the
harnessing of power to the to the
textile industry four hundred years or
more with the early stages of the
Industrial Revolution the UK was the was
the world leader then then the United
States came in at first well behind
while behind the UK copied the
technologies that were available in the
UK but changed some of its rules about
things like our patent system compared
to the British patent system Mars was
much more democratic much easier for
small inventors to get access to we
pioneered a very different form of
universities and a very different
commitment to education and because of
those different kinds of rules we became
we became the world leader so in this
chart that I showed you before about
world leadership this is the point where
the Netherlands takes over as the world
leader this was the point where the UK
takes over and then this most recently
is the spot for the United States the
same kind of dynamic that we talked
about in terms of companies operates
amongst these these countries as well
there was new entry the United States in
particular was a brand new country with
new rules very different from the rules
that others had used we saw cases of
copying the United States copied
technologies and rules that worked well
in Britain Britain after World War two
copied things that had worked well in
the United States we've also had cases
of large-scale migration I mentioned the
migration into into the Netherlands in
the the period when they were surging
ahead the united states as a new nation
of course attracted many migrants as
well and continues to attract migrants
in those areas with those sets of skills
that were will where we'll let them come
in so entry migration copying all
operate at this same scale between
countries just as they do between
companies and to just illustrate that
process let me just tell you a little
bit more of the story of Pennsylvania as
a new set of rules its own country until
it became part of the new United States
Pennsylvania was a Dominion that was
given to William Penn by king charles ii
penn set out the charter wrote down a
charter for pennsylvania and innovated
in terms of the rules and certain things
like legally protected guarantee of
religion Penson this is the way
pennsylvania will be run then people who
were interested in living under those
kinds of rules were attracted to
pennsylvania penn actually went the
netherlands in 1670 and tried to tried
to recruit people from there as well as
from germany to come live in his new his
new country and ultimately other
colonies in the united states copied
this innovation of a legally guaranteed
right to freedom of revolution to
freedom of religion and it became a part
of our our constitution notice that in
this process the dynamic that we usually
think about as the one that drives
innovations and rules people vote to
have a change in the rules or they vote
to have some representatives who then go
change the rules this was not the
dynamic that got us a legal protection
of the freedom of religion in this in
this period so the question that we need
to ask ourselves is what if what if
there were no new countries what if
because of the conventions that we've
now established about protecting
boundaries what if because of those
conventions that no country can invade
another country
we stop this process of the introduction
of new national rule sets that can
compete with existing ones that can
innovate in ways that the existing ones
find hard to innovate with so think
about how did we create a new country in
the United States we actually did it
through through military conquest
I mean pen pen was given quote the land
by king charles ii but there were people
living here and pen pen was actually
relatively humane about this and tried
to pay the indians who were living there
to leave but in a sense we were able to
create a new country in the united
states because of violent military
conquest of a piece of land that was
occupied by some other people and said
we're gonna take whatever rule system
was there in place before and put in
place a new one so should we should we
rethink this convention about giving war
a chance should we should we try this
again unfortunately this was basically
the logic behind thinking about the
invasion in Iraq and the invasion in
Afghanistan there are many conflicting
and complicating factors in the invasion
in Iraq but the invasion in Afghanistan
was something where there was broad
international consensus that this was
the right thing to do to go in
militarily and try and change the rule
system that was in place there and it
still turned out very badly so for
better or for worse it's almost certain
going ahead that we're not going to see
the kind of conquest of territory that
led to the introduction of Pennsylvania
as a new colony or the United States as
a new country and then the question is
does this does this mean that this
dynamic of competition and entry and
reallocation which drove improvement in
the rules which in turn drove
improvement the technologies and
standards of living are we about to
enter a phase where this process is is
shutting down so what what I want to get
you to think about the application now
if the theory of history here is it's
the it's the coevolution of rules and
technology which have driven progress
and that rules have progressed in the
same way that industries progress
through
competition entry reallocation copying
what if we could continue that entry
process without some form of conquest
could we as humans come up with rules
about how we change rules so that we
create this potential for ongoing
innovation even at the level of national
rule sets now to try and build the case
that that application of this theory is
possible that we can keep coevolution of
rules and technology moving ahead and we
can do it through entry competition
reallocation migration let me talk about
how China got out of the trap that it
was stuck in for for a thousand years
because of a historical accident that
did involve conquest so this part
doesn't generalize but because of a
historical accident a very small piece
of China was under a different system of
administrative control from the rest of
China it was under the control of the
British it was a place like Pennsylvania
that people could come to if they wanted
to live under a different set of rules
than say the rules that were operating
on the mainland the rules that the
British brought into Hong Kong were the
modern rules that we take for granted of
a modern economy Hong Kong especially in
the post-world War two ERA grew very
rapidly as a commercial initially
commercial manufacturing center later as
a financial as a financial hub Hong Kong
grew very rapidly the Chinese watching
this demonstration affect close by
started to take advantage of it by
creating for special economic zones
along the the coastline in China where
rules that had been developed in Hong
Kong could be brought in one at a time
in small measure within these special
zones so the Chinese did not try to
change everything in the whole nation
all at once but when the leadership was
persuaded that they really did have to
move forward as a nation instead of
continuing to lag farther and farther
behind they were able to take advantage
of the close experience of Hong Kong and
then replicate it in other special small
zones
where the rules and then the
technologies of the modern world were
brought into China that was then
followed by a series of cities along the
coast in China so this gradual evolution
from one very small spot to to several
others and the upshot was that whereas
the last graph that I showed you stopped
in 1950 now with a slightly different
scale because it's $2,000 dollars in
purchasing power of the year 2000 you
can see how starting in the 1970s income
per capita finally starts to grow in
China and then takes off and goes
through this this surge this
unprecedented increase in standards of
living this this increase at rates that
we've never seen before in human history
if you want to see this in ratio terms
relative to the United States this shows
you income per capita in China as a
percentage of income per capita in the
United States and you can see that there
there's no catch up at all through the
through the 1970s and then this
astonishing process of convergence
that's taken place since since the late
1970s so the changes in the rules that
the Chinese were able to implement by
starting with small areas by
experimenting with those areas by using
those areas as places where you could
copy not just the technologies that our
idea like and copyable but even copy the
institutions by bringing them in first
to Hong Kong then to the rest of China
this process of copying rules and
technologies enabled this astonishing
improvement in standards of living and
the force which is just turning the
corner for the world so that worldwide
income inequality is now finally
starting to shrink rather than grow
partly because of that continuing
divergence that we saw for almost a
thousand years between the west and
China
so what would it take to generalize from
this this Chinese experience and create
the potential for new entry at the level
of national rule systems the first thing
we'll have to do is rethink sovereignty
sovereignty has many components there to
that I want to distinguish here one is
sovereignty in the sense of
internationally recognized borders and
we have come worldwide to a new
consensus that internationally
recognized borders cannot be violated
and that's an extremely important
development in human history it will
mean that we will no longer have wars of
conquest of territory or for that matter
conquests like the ones that that led to
led to the Pennsylvania but we won't
have Wars like World War 1 and to either
that needs to be preserved and almost
surely will be preserved going forward
but you can distinguish sovereignty in
the sense of the ultimate say over what
happens within a board within a kind of
a predefined set of borders you can
distinguish that from a notion of
administrative control that on paper
what the British had in Hong Kong was a
delegated responsibility for
administrative control within a piece of
sovereign Chinese territory and if we
think with open minds there are many
places around the world where the
sovereign territory of one nation could
be granted to granted given
administrative responsibility for that
piece of territory could be granted to
other nations or consortiums of nations
to partnerships to other kinds of groups
who could facilitate the transfer not
just of technologies but even systems
systems of rules and there's no reason
why this couldn't be negotiated
voluntarily looking back Hong Kong was
probably the most successful economic
development program in human history
there's no reason why something like
that couldn't be done intentionally
voluntarily as part of a mutually
beneficial agreement rather than by the
kind of force that that set up that set
up Hong Kong so if we distinguish the
borders from
who's in control and are willing to
think flexibly about who's in control
there are many more options which will
open up here and this is particularly
powerful if you think about setting up
new systems of control in areas where
almost no one lives because then you
could replicate something like the
dynamic in Pennsylvania where you could
propose new rules different rules from
those applying locally perhaps even
different rules that apply anywhere in
the world and people can choose to opt
in and operate under those those new
kinds of rules so you could have much
more experimentation much more freedom
for people to move into new places and
continued progress in the sense of
competition between systems of rules the
other piece that we'd probably need to
to make this work is to rethink
citizenship that you can think about
citizenship is partly being about
residency you can be granted residency
rights in a particular place but
citizenship typically involves some
notion of voices well some ability to
vote or to have some control over the
political system but we're already used
to distinguishing between these two
these two notions there are people who
can move into one country as foreign as
residents but who are not nationalized
citizens and who therefore don't have
voice so you could imagine in these new
administrative unit units people who
might move there who might retain their
citizenship rights in the sense of voice
retain that in their country of origin
but not necessarily have the same kinds
of rights of Rights of voice in the
place that they moved to and some other
group of citizens might be the ones who
actually have voice and voting over the
the rules in one of these administrative
administrative zones hong kong had that
characteristic hong kong was under
democratic control in the post-world war
ii era there were voters in in the UK
who elected a prime minister who
appointed an administrator for hong kong
so it was not a case of authoritarian
rule but in fact it was a case of
democratic rule it just turned out not
to be a democracy that involved the
local
local residents everyone in Hong Kong
lived there in the same way that someone
with a green card might come and live in
the United States and if we're willing
to allow for that kind of possibility
again it could free up our notions about
exactly where in the world and under
what circumstances and what kinds of
terms new kinds of economic and
political Arrangements could be put in
place the last thing that we have to do
to to deliver on this program is to
rethink scale if you think about
economic development which is the
application that most concerns me we
typically think of either the village or
the nation will do something will change
things at the level of the village of
the nation but go back to that
discussion we had earlier about the
power of more people leading to more
ideas leading to economic benefits the
modern representation of that power of
ideas that we gained access to from
immediate access to people our urban
areas we cluster in urban areas because
we want those benefits of being around
many other people and we suffer the
costs of having a lot less land per
person because the ideas per person that
we can have are so much greater in a
city so the scale to think about this
kind of new development and for changing
the prospects for for all poor countries
in the world right now is the same kind
of scale that the Chinese were thinking
about when they looked at Hong Kong then
had the special economic zones than the
open cities we need to think about
city-states as the as the unit where we
could undertake this kind of innovation
and create create the opportunities for
very different kinds of systems of rules
and very rapid translation of the
benefits from the rest of the world to
those those new cities this is going to
be an extremely important challenge for
the world to face in the coming century
something on the order of five five or
more potentially as many as 8 billion
people will if economic growth takes
place at any kind of reasonable rate
five to eight billion people will want
to move to
cities will be able to move to cities a
very small fraction the world population
will be left in rural areas producing
all the food we need and almost everyone
will want to lead at live in cities and
it will be an enormous challenge for us
to provide the kinds of well-run cities
that can lead to real economic benefits
real improvement in standards of living
rather than the kinds of dysfunctional
cities we see in some parts of the
developing world where the existing
rules aren't able to keep up can't
improve can't cope with the challenges
that they face so what if we really
needed places for billions of people
five five billion people or more how
much land on earth would it actually
take if you take the world surface area
represented as dots compress it to a
rectangle like this and then ask suppose
people could move into places like Hong
Kong so Hong Kong like densities how
much land would it take to create urban
areas for 8 billion people it turns out
it's a tiny fraction of the surface area
on the earth and there's an enormous
amount of land on earth which is right
now very underutilized not suitable for
agriculture but could easily be used to
create these new urban urban spots so
finding the land would really be no
challenge and carrying out a program
like this even at scale the challenge
will be for us to rethink things that
we've taken for granted about rules and
how rules change how people opt into
them and opt out how they control them
what options they have and what kinds of
arrangements countries can enter into
about what to do within their own
borders what ways existing countries can
work together to create new kinds of
arrangements that transfer rural
technology rural systems as well as
technologies across borders so there's
really nothing but certain kinds of
presumptions and emotional reactions
that hold us back from doing something
that could be terribly important for
helping people throughout the world
old ketchup and potentially even keeping
technology going at the frontier there's
a there's a law that's referred to as
card wells law that says that no nation
remains technologically innovative for
long we've been able to enjoy continued
accelerating economic growth and
technological innovation but only
because that process of innovation has
been able to move to different places
across the globe now we'd like to
believe that the United States will
remain the worldwide leader forever into
the the far future but if you take the
long now timeframe seriously of the next
10,000 years
history doesn't give you a lot of
confidence that any nation even the
United States can remain the
technological leader but if there's
still some potential for new places to
emerge
new systems to be tried places where new
people can go often young innovative
people the ambitious people who moved
into Holland this may be important not
just in helping the rest of the world
catch up but even keeping innovation
going at faster and faster rates out at
out at the cutting edge so there's a
there's a big challenge
INRI and just getting ourselves to
rethink what's possible what we could do
but there's an enormous amount at stake
here this map zeroes in on on Africa
which is the other part of the world
which right right now stands out as
being very very devoid of light there's
very limited GDP very limited
opportunities for people to consume to
consume light there and if you want a
picture to remember about what that
means in terms of the quality of life
remember this picture this is a picture
of students in Guinea reading their
textbooks at the airport because this
was the only place where they could get
light at night to do their to do their
schoolwork
it's a solved technical problem about
how to generate electricity and get it
to homes so students don't have to go
sit at the airport to read their books
and it's a salt tuck it's a solved
political social problem to create rules
that can lead to the implementation of
those technical systems that
light to these to these kinds of young
people so as you evaluate this theory of
the history and this this application
and you run up against the inevitable
reaction that we could never create new
countries you could never have an
agreement to set aside a piece of
territory and create something like a
Hong Kong you could never have a place
where people opt-in and opt-out but
where the political control might be
from a very different location but as
you think about all of those all of
those objections think about explaining
it to one of these kids and telling them
why we think the best solution is for
you to just spend as long as it takes
you know maybe another thousand lire
years as in China to wait for somehow
your own internal systems of rules to
transform so you can get access to the
kinds of things that we we take for
granted Thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]